hey guys how's it going so for today's
unboxing it's a very small small tiny
box but this is something that I ordered
a long time ago I actually ordered this
before the air pods even came out and
this is just a strap for your air box
that's it
so one of the things that surprised me
the most about the air box is how much I
actually really liked that I just kept
achill I made fun of them you made fun
of them we all made fun of them we're
still sort of making fun of them but
these have been the only headphones that
I have been using as soon as I got them
yes we still do fall out a little bit
but they surprisingly did not fall out
at all when I was working out for a
while for like a few weeks and then I
stopped so I have to go back again maybe
my ear possible encourage me to go back
but even running on a treadmill they
actually stayed in my ears most of the
time only a few casualties for this
potentially to come in and II I'm not
sure this could either get in way or
actually make it even worse so I also
tried the little clips if you flip on to
your air pods but those do not work out
at all because you have to take them on
and off every time you wanted to use
your air pot so I'd rather just fish
around on the floor for mine instead of
having to remove and replace them every
time so hopefully those air pod straps
with wire incredible packaging it's a
great
well the unboxing is done and here it is
this is just a little wire held together
by a little quick peek I it's noisy here
oh it isn't magic I can't freaking get
it outta here is this is a very hose
garbage this is essentially a piece of a
piece of string like you could make it
yourself you could just this is this is
absurd I can't believe I paid money for
this am i on drugs please apply by
sliding the head of the strap into the
pause that's tugging and pulling toward
attachment a stretch of hair the strap
extreme stressing in the strap will
result in permanent hair frequent
exposure or friction with our clip so we
make on this there's a lot of
disclaimers on this let's see if it
works
the good part is this is actually so
light that I feel like Ellis tugging its
plugin it's a very very light cable ok
my air pods have been connected I'm
listening to a sweet tune mmm okay it's
not connected to my head
please hold now playing on Justine dare
pause try it over here around my head
like this so this is what it looks like
I can't even turn around because I'm in
such a tight space well how does it look
from the back it looks good they both
fall out I mean the good news is oh gosh
my guess the good news is if they fall
out they're both together like what if I
do this ok what if I do this I've an
idea
so I tie this like oh boom that's I'm
going to work my head's not I think it
was a little bit bigger to the I tie it
around my neck around my ears like this
and then I just go like this and put
them inside of my ear so it's basically
going to be cutting off not only the
circulation of I guess you have me
nightly sure if your circulation in your
ears I'm sure there's gotta be something
going on in there it's not that way now
and just fold my ear down just a little
bit like this and then bring this around
oh this is a great idea
I mean it hurts a little bit like you
know pain is only temporary and the mind
of holder
I'm just letting your she's stupid shut
up alright um did I wear it with a
headband to move it this way that work
oh no ok I'm just going to be completely
honest do this is this is probably going
to make matters even worse
I don't think this is going to help you
but if you are sitting stationary and
you're on an airplane or something like
that this is definitely where I do plan
on using this because I have lost my ear
pod airpot err it's not me your body
levels in your ears air as an air pause
so just make sure we don't forget our
place I have to
as many flight attendants help me find
one of these that have fallen underneath
of the chair underneath inside of like
an arm seat so this is going to be super
helpful but if if you're not moving
around a lot and you're just sitting
living I mean these are going to stay in
do the off-chance does it itself what
the heck am I saying what am I saying
well I'm trying to justify the fact that
I bought a piece of string from my
airpot how much were these how much did
I pay for that God somebody pour me a
glass of wine there's nobody here
all right how much nothing something it
looks like $15.99 those one on eBay for
9.99 and on Amazon it is well it looks
like it used to be $20 and now it's
$9.99 good because if you pay any more
than five dollars for this little tiny
piece of nothing you're crazy
so I'm crazy because I bought this so
long ago I mean remember how much I paid
for it probably cool price though I like
this there's a little illustration here
which also quite look like the
illustrations I didn't peek at the point
you know well thank you guys so much for
watching let me know if you guys have
any other suggestions for a fun text
Tuesday even though it's not Tuesday and
if it is Tuesday cool anything you'd
like to see me unbox or review let me
know what you guys think in the comments
below and let me know what you guys
think of these strap-on earpods airpot
air pod strapped on air paws trap you
know what I'm saying I'll see you guys
later
oh my god wait I feel what we're doing
it's like the menacing tiny this is
probably seeing writable it's my
favorite movement I wouldn't pick far
back in the day when they were working
on that film excuse me yeah my fault
about that old look at this clause look
at the cheese it looks